[Music]
works of art grace the walls of our
homes the walls of our museums and
sometimes the walls of city streets
that's the venue where a mother and son
team have been hard at work painting
murals that blend art pop culture and
social commentary creating inspiring
works that become treasured features of
their neighborhoods from houston maria
villarreal has their story and the story
behind their unusual names
the idea is that somebody can post up on
a bike right here and it'll be like
we're all riding together and we're like
just going to
kind of explore the city together this
is the kind of art that's changing
houston's landscape he's a local legend
everybody knows donkey boy if not now
they will soon alex roman and his mother
sylvia have created this cult following
as donkey boy and donkey mom
the hispanic duo is known for their
distinct style of painting murals that
combines traditional art with modern
messages and characters why donkey mom
and donkey boy where did this come from
when i was younger like people doubted
me and they said i wouldn't make it as
an artist but i kept rolling with it
stubborn yeah and if you research
donkeys they're very stubborn they're
hard-working and they're loyal once you
gain their trust which i think are all
characteristics that i have are you okay
with it though yeah i like it and it's
true
if you watch them long enough you'll
notice they don't speak much
but they talk through their art
with each spray and each stroke she does
something and i'll come in right behind
her and do something else we just have
this flow already that flow keeps them
busy with new art projects booked
through the end of the year who's the
that boss quick but you cracked the whip
you know whatever
she's my mom what do i do i've learned
from her sylvia began her art career
decades ago in mexico often using oil
paints and spending weeks if not months
on a piece it wasn't traditional for you
to keep working
but when she became a mother her husband
asked that she stay home and raise the
kids
essentially putting her art career on
hold i remember being five years old and
i would see her paintings at different
people's houses and uh i just couldn't
believe that she painted them my mom
still is like my hero i just had this
like itch to be an artist and it came
from her obviously that itch pushed him
to leave texas and follow his dreams in
los angeles was there a point where you
were broke try to do this juan tosano's
marriage
yeah
there's yeah there was years where like
i mean i wasn't making anything
you know my bank account was in the
negative i just had to figure it out and
i'm still figuring it out just grab a
brush grab the paint about 10 years ago
the two started working together and
found success in houston lending their
name and their talent to community
events like this one where students can
see living examples of successful latino
artists we have amazing
latino artist it's still like
ah man
like that's a pipe dream like get a real
job that's not gonna take you anywhere i
don't know why that still exists which
frame do you like that mentality pushed
alex to get involved with break free a
group that introduces young kids to
different types of art i didn't know how
to draw the heart so he came to help me
he helped me he did the
frame around oh the frame around the
heart for these students this is about
more than just art i feel like
especially within the past years
stuff has been hard but
music and art has really helped me to
contain my feelings and deal with them
deal yes ma'am i don't want people to
feel how i felt and struggle how i
struggled so
if i can make it a little bit easier and
and open some doors
i think that's what i what i'm supposed
to do
donkey mom and donkey boy are hoping to
inspire the next generation of artists
to find a way to merge the old with the
new
creating their own distinct styles no
matter how different it may seem
let's see
for cbs this morning saturday video real
houston texas
i mean we already loved him and then the
eyes it was great the eye in there and
it's great that a kid can watch that
story and watch donkey boy and say i
want to be an artist and maybe they were
worried they couldn't do it but then
yeah it's inspiration right yeah i
wonder though if there's ever any
creative differences and probably donkey
mom wins
right definitely
asked who was in charge how fast that
was yeah
always for sure